A careful examination of the period from
1873 to 1896 provides useful insight
into our current era of political division
and social separation. After the Civil War,
America's economic expansion was halted by
the Long Depression — the longest contraction
in US history, coinciding with
a society in flux, as America
transitioned from an agricultural
republic to an industrialized nation.
Political parties at the presidential
level remained unchanged, but at the
Congressional level, politics became
increasingly destabilized as we still
fought over the Civil War. This is much
like today, with candidates litigating
issues that have been fought for the
past 40 years. Changes seen in the
parties over the past few decades will
not be short-lived. We are living in an
era of social upheavals, when citizens
are constructing new social orders
and our parties are shifting to address
these upheavals. The trend towards
populism within the GOP and leftism in
the Democratic Party are symptoms of
these changes and are unlikely to abate.
What do you think about the changes in
America's political parties? Let us know
in the comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.